This is the Halloween video,
and this is Jess from
Mortem Manor Haunted House.
And of course,
by the nature of the industry,
this video is gonna have a
little bit of simulated blood and gore,
but it's just all Hollywood nonsense.
And while we're not gonna try and
jump scare you, the audience,
we are gonna try and jump scare
Kevin, the Backyard Scientist,
who's on his way here now.
So if you're okay with all that,
let's scare Kevin.
♪ (bombastic horror music)
No matter how much you
suspend disbelief,
there has to be a reason
why all of this stuff's in here.
Yeah. Oh, hello.
So the narrative
we came up with is
the family that used to
reside in this manor,
the Mortison family,
thus Mortem Manor,
was sort of your hunter of evil,
collector of accursed artifacts.
Unfortunately, the Mortison family
no longer runs the property.
They have disappeared.
I'm not at liberty to say
what happened to them.
Okay.
All I can say is that
some other individuals have
taken over the property in their place,
and they're being a little bit more
loosey-goosey with the artifacts
and the potential power
that they hold.
I like how you're having
me going first here.
Yeah. Oh yeah.
I mean, I've already seen it,
so why ruin the surprise?
Yeah. That's true.
I mean...
So we've got a bit more lighting
in here than usual for the cameras.
Yep.
So, okay.
It's gory, but it's obviously fake gore.
I'm guessing with the lights down...
Especially, yeah.
Yeah.
This whole room is beet red
when you're walking through,
and there's just a lot of nastiness.
Yeah. Yeah, there really is.
I'm gonna totally leave it
up to you guys,
what you blur and what you show,
because it's your channel.
Now I've gotta look at, like,
the monetization
restrictions on YouTube here.
You might just be seeing
a load of pixels at this point.
But yeah, that's blood
and guts there, alright.
How do you make it look wet?
So these guys,
anything in the attraction
that is more or less
a creature but doesn't move,
we refer to as a static.
So grandpa over here isn't
gonna be popping out at us.
He just sits there. That's all he does.
Okay. Thanks for the—
The blood is almost like if
you were to take pigment
and add it to a clear lacquer.
So something that you would add
to a table to give it a shine.
And as a result, we probably
applied that blood originally
— it gets touchups
from here and there —
Yeah.
Five or six years ago,
and it's still shines.
Alright.
And we'll show you later on,
that shine, we don't
just put that on props.
We can put that on costuming.
Alright.
We can put that on props,
on weapons, and—
I am so glad that I'm gonna be
the one behind the scenes later.
Oh yeah.
'Cause this is...
This is about what I'm
okay with in a haunted house.
There's more light than usual.
Yeah.
And there's someone just
reassuring as we go around.
Yeah. Just that casual,
Yeah.
"None of this is real,
and this is why it's not real."
And here we are walking into
what I humourously call
the biggest liability in the house.
Everything here is simulated horror,
but staircases are staircases.
Right.
We have a saying on set,
"No scares on stairs"
for obvious reasons.
Oh yeah. 'Cause if something...
Oh yes. Exactly.
We find when
human beings are scared,
you can never predict
what they're gonna do.
So we try to confine in which areas
we're going to do those scares.
So nobody goes and chucks
themselves down a staircase,
which I can thankfully say
after almost seven years,
nobody has yet chucked
themselves down the staircase.
Alright.
I'm hoping Kevin keeps that going.
I'd hate to ruin that record today.
Obviously it's a little bit quiet
in here compared to normally.
But at this point, usually you have
music a couple rooms down.
There's a storm actively
taking place on the staircase.
So you are completely,
from all directions,
immersed in theming and senses.
Just a lot of sensorial input
hitting at once.
(compressed air hissing)
As much as we tried,
we can't get spiders
to naturally just make the
cobwebs where we need them.
And I've got a couple
blank spots today, so...
I've just realised,
that is a hot glue gun...
That is 100 percent... a hot glue gun...
...connected to an air compressor.
I'm gonna be very careful.
That is just, hot glue tip.
Oh yeah. Yep.
And an air line. Do you
wanna make some webs?
I've got a blank canvas here.
Yeah, sure.
Just ready to go.
There's safety gear as well.
Hot glue's most likely
not going to kill you,
but anybody who's ever gotten it
stuck on their finger knows...
Yeah.
Not the most pleasant.
Alright.
There we go.
(both laughing)
Wow.
I tell people it's about as close to
being Spider-Man as you're gonna get.
I really hope that's shown up on
camera with the back lighting.
That's ridiculous!
(laughing)
And we'll go through set by set,
and we will just cover it
top to bottom.
That was a whole—
A whole stick of glue
just went through there.
Oh, it will burn through it.
There's a reason I got
sticks and sticks over there.
Just doing the cobwebbing
in a set like this,
we could go through
five or six of these guys.
A lot of people don't realize when
they're walking through, it's yeah,
things look dilapidated, things
look as if they've been neglected.
But a lot of people
have to put in a lot of work
to make it look like nobody's been
doing anything for ages.
Alright.
There we go.
I mean...
(belly laughs)
She is fun, isn't she?
That's ridiculous.
If you wanna be my guest,
we'll keep going forward.
And I'll show you all the fun stuff.
(shrieking, clattering)
Ah, yeah.
I should have mentioned
before we came in today...
This is with the lights on as well!
Couple of the props,
if I want to turn them off,
I gotta get up high
into some weird spots.
Yeah, thanks. Thanks.
So I just didn't.
Yep. (giggles)
Yep.
But then, at least,
I haven't got that sorta—
I mean, this is gory as anything.
Oh yes.
But I don't have that
feeling of dread, because...
I am being escorted around.
(chuckles) Yeah.
There is much more
light in this room.
Kevin's gonna have an
interesting time, I think.
And it's great too, 'cause especially
when you hyperfill a space like this,
there is that moment
where you walk in and...
What does what?
Is he just gonna sit there?
Is that a person?
Is that a dummy?
Yeah. Is that a static?
Is that an animatronic?
Is that a real living human being?
Sorry, that's really gross.
We're just gonna have to blur that.
Oh yes.
She's one of the earlier ones.
Yeah, that's just getting blurred.
If anybody asks,
she was an organ donor.
Not by choice, but she is now.
So that's where we're at.
And the organ is
apparently the face!
Yes. One of the
more important ones.
I think you might need it to live.
(groan)
You put the smells in
as well then?
Yeah. So it is worth noting,
there's a lot of rotting food
in here, but at the same time,
there is no rotting food in here.
Yeah.
You've got the smell.
You've got the looks.
You've got— yeah.
Yeah.
Hidden throughout the sets,
we genuinely...
this little guy right here for ya
is pumping fake smells into it.
Right.
And then...
Oh... that is a shark.
That is very much a shark.
Is that an animatronic?
Does that...?
Oh, he's gonna come out
and he is going to take a, well,
He's going to try to take
a bite outta Kevin.
So how far does it come out?
Oh, he comes fully out.
The mouth is articulated.
Wow!
And now's a great time too,
to just bring up the fact
that so far everything
that you've seen up here,
including this big guy,
and another very big guy
I'm gonna show you later,
had to come up that front staircase
that we climbed on the way out there.
Okay, yeah.
So this effect right here,
we call it a laser swamp.
Oh!
We run a laser straight
through just a bunch of fog.
And it being a condensed
beam of light,
the only thing that's
refracting is the fog itself.
Right.
One of the nice features as well is
if I have an actor coming through...
Yeah?
All I have to do is... that.
Ohh! Oh, I don't like that!
(both laughing)
As we continue through,
there's a reason
why haunted houses like
this serpentine.
Yeah. I just hate it when
you're sending me in first.
Well, not only is it because
we can fit more into more space,
but it also allows us
to do stuff like this.
Yeah.
Where in the matter of seconds
I can be there, I can be here.
(loud slam)
I could even be over here.
You had to slam the door,
and you had to slam it so hard
that the entire wall went...
She's built to take it.
And the nice thing is,
when you get just a little bit of rattle
to it, that adds some noise.
I have latches over here that
don't even latch to anything.
They are designed to
just jingle as we slam.
There's a really ominous hissing
noise coming from up there.
(chuckles) Yes.
Like, really ominous.
So the entire house is
running compressed air.
All of my moving parts
here are pneumatics,
which I'm gonna show you
here a little bit later.
Alright.
So as we round the corner
here, you're gonna see
we're coming up on
a really interesting set.
Now, what we did
right up here is...
(shrieking, rattling)
Yeah...
It works.
Yeah.
Even with camera lighting
on, it works.
Yeah. And then he's just gonna
go right back into his hole,
and he's gonna wait for the
very next victim to show up.
Did that freefall drop?
Oh yeah.
There's a piston
that's holding it up,
and when it activates the piston,
just completely depressurizes.
And then when she's ready
to go, right back up.
Up until now, it's all been
twisty turns and tight corridors.
Yeah.
This is open.
Not only do you have to
have variation in sets,
you have to
have variations in space.
There can't be a consistent
throughline throughout,
because we, by nature,
don't want you
to get comfortable
with what you're seeing.
Wow.
So this is personally
our largest set.
You wouldn't believe it.
Oh!
Oh, yes.
And that's the big guy.
Not only— And it's not like
an amusement park,
where it's a nice, cool, big thing,
and it's way back there.
Right.
And you get to go, "Oh, that's..."
You can walk up to that.
You walk straight up to him.
Every single part of him is
soft and light enough
that if you bump into it...
May I?
It's not gonna kill you. By all means.
I'm not used to—
Wait, does this move?
Oh yeah.
He's an animatronic.
Oh!
He is fully articulated.
This feels like the exit.
This is...
Yeah, so...
Still expect that to...
(laughs)
It is an option, if I
gotta move actors around.
I just figured that you would
put one more at the end.
Just to—
We have the option.
which actually does
bring us into...
You did make it through, but we
have a little bit of a problem here.
I mean, I went through
on easy mode
with lighting and no people.
No people. So I think we need
to resolve that issue.
I've got a couple people on site.
We're gonna put them on
costumes and makeup.
Well, when I say I have
a couple people on site,
you're people and you're on site.
I was wondering, 'cause I knew I was
gonna be part of this somehow.
But I didn't know if I was gonna be
pushing buttons behind the scenes.
You don't have a master
control panel. You just have...
We don't really need one.
...people in the maze.
Yeah, so I figure
since you're here,
and I have the option to
throw you in zombie makeup...
Well, I'd be remiss if
I didn't just do that anyway.
Yep.
So we're gonna get you
all nasty looking,
make you look undead,
and at some point upstairs,
you're gonna be in there to
absolutely wreck Kevin's day.
Sorry, Kevin...!
And right off the bat,
you are already looking...
Well, for one, you're looking—
It's very stiff.
Oh yes. We're gonna
have to find the arm hole.
Okay. Yep.
We're gonna have—
That's actually glummed to
itself with dried blood, cool.
We are gonna have a nice little
Lady and the Tramp moment here,
where I'm gonna
meet you in the middle.
And we're just gonna pull.
And I'm gonna show you.
And all the way through.
Okay.
Ngh-aah!
Perfect!
What we got there— Yep.
That's very tight.
It's a little bit gnarly.
Yeah, now, a good thing
is you're undead.
So you don't have full range
of movement anyway.
That's good, 'cause I'm already
gonna be going like this.
Yes, and...
That's alright.
Now that we've got you looking
absolutely disgusting...
No offense.
From here on up...
From here on up.
I think we're gonna
continue the motif,
and we're just gonna keep
griming and griming
until you're at the level that, well,
the entire ensemble matches.
♪ (whimsical Halloween music)
And you're done.
Okay.
(laughs)
I can't see—
Wow, okay!
Hold on.
There is a better— I'm just gonna
have to use my phone.
Oh, that's full Hollywood.
I love it.
I'm glad you do.
Oh, that's so good.
That's got Beetlejuice vibes about it.
Yes.
That's so nice.
Thank you!
Alright, let's go scare Kevin.
Alright, so do you think of
yourself more like a corpse,
a reanimated corpse,
or a vampire type thing?
Where are we going with this?
I'm bad at acting,
so I feel like if I can
just be a dead body
that just jumps out
and scares him...
Ahh.
that's probably the best option for me,
'cause he's probably gonna
recognize me and be less intimidated.
Rrright.
Whereas if I am a corpse
that he just thinks is a dummy,
And then I can get him.
Ah, right.
That sounds like the best shot.
We do have a lot of these
kind of bodies
and that kind of stuff sitting around.
How convincing— If I'm—
So maybe, if I hit him here...
and then he thinks
the scare's already over, yeah!
And yeah, if you're
either over there—
I don't wanna ruin the makeup.
Or even just — (gargle) — curled up.
Yeah.
Yeah, over here.
And then at the last second,
you can just...
Alright, so...
(chuckles)
So okay, let's try this.
Get you something like that.
If I'm gonna do that...
Kick it way back, and then—
I'm gonna take the shoes off,
'cause they're a big giveaway
that this is obviously human.
Those are not haunting shoes.
Yeah, exactly. They're funny.
Okay, but assuming the shoes
are off and they're in dark—
I don't wanna ruin the makeup though.
So let's— It's gonna be...
(soft chuckle)
And then his attention
will hopefully be up there.
Yeah.
And then it's a case of...
So how do you go from zero
to a hundred that fast?
'Cause I feel like there's a
warmup period where—
Yeah, you definitely gotta be up.
D'aah!
Yeah. You definitely gotta
be up a little bit more.
This is not a—
Or those legs are gonna be a-flailing.
Yeah. So it's gotta be
something like...
Raaagh!
That had a lean forward. Okay.
(laughs)
Right, right.
Alright.
You might wanna have
the body up a little bit more
and have the head
more like right here.
Yep.
'Cause—
(hard bump) Agh!
I'll move the pillow so I don't
whack my head on that.
Yeah.
(hard bump)
Aaaah!
Don't double whack!
I'll put the pillow there!
What I can't get is the speed
with which to go from this to...
Raagh!
Try for something guttural too.
Like, urraaAAgh!
RuuaAAgh!
Yeah. Let your inner zombie flow.
Alright, let's do it.
Let's do this.
The scariest thing I've done is
Haunted Mansion at Disney World, so.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
I have no idea what's
gonna happen in here.
I've never heard of it before,
but it seems scary.
Oh no.
(nervous chuckle)
The moment of truth.
Uh-huh.
I'm actually a
little bit envious of him.
Just a little.
Here he goes. He's gonna be
moving into that opening room,
which is this one.
Opening room here. Okay.
It's got a nice ambience.
Oh, he wants to play a game.
Tell the family we have guests.
I don't wanna play a game!
(sparking)
(evil cackling)
(both giggling)
I shouldn't be laughing this much.
I would hate that.
I would absolutely hate that.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of everything.
I'm looking at it to see
if its eyes are moving.
I don't know what's real
and what's not.
Now, no scares on stairs.
You said that.
No scares on stairs.
Alright.
That's correct.
It seems like a
fairly innocent staircase.
Just a nice...
No, they're not gonna scare me
on a staircase 'cause I could fall down.
So I feel like I'm safe here.
He's on his own now, right?
Apart from the
camera guy, obviously.
He's heading up the stairs.
He's gonna be heading into library now.
I feel like this is so much worse,
'cause it's all focused on me.
There's none of that, like,
pack safety thing.
I feel like a lone zebra,
and Tom Scott is the lion
hunting me down right now.
There's that moment
you have to scan everything.
Hey!
Aaah!
Oh my god.
You don't belong in here,
do you?
Is that real?
That one's real.
(group giggling)
Something else got him.
Now, time to go.
(shrieking, clattering)
Oh, no!
Now, once he gets to
about around there,
he's gonna be entering Clown.
And that's when I need
to run to the chapel.
That's gonna be
the opportune moment
for you to get up there,
get in position.
Okay.
Okay, now we're entering
a surgery room,
and this, I really feel like this is
where my insides get taken out of.
I have been expecting you.
Yes, you'll do very nicely.
I've already had
my booster, thanks.
How about another?!
(shriek)
(maniacal laughter)
Oh well, maybe
the infirmary isn't your...
Oh man.
...to your liking.
It really smells like,
scary in here too.
Go on.
(terrified shout)
It's a shark!
(frightened chuckle)
(both giggling)
So far, so good.
This is...
(muffled creaking)
I hear creaking footsteps,
and I dunno if it's the camera man
or somebody waiting
around the corner.
Okay, so where's Kevin
heading through now?
He's— He was—
The fact that she's
resetting right now,
I say now's probably
gonna be your chance.
If you wanna start moving,
I'll keep an eye on cam,
so we'll know when he
gets around this corner.
Alright, let's go.
Ooh, this is cool.
(canned shrieking)
(startled shout)
No-ho-ho!
Oh, what is this?
They put some kind of...
I don't know what this is.
It feels like a bridge
that's about to fall down.
The floor shakes.
(loud smack)
(maniacal cackling)
(canned shrieking resumes)
What if I go under the laser?
Then they can't see me 'cause
I'm gonna be under the laser.
(hesitant chuckling)
Impervious!
(startled yelp)
(cackling)
(walls clattering)
Piece by piece,
a part of my walls!
(witchy cackling)
I don't wanna be part of the walls!
So this next room
really looks like...
...a doozy.
There's a giant spider
hanging from the wall.
There's a lot of people
with knives standing around,
who may or may not be real.
This is like a big room,
so there's probably gonna be
some good stuff here.
Shoes, I've forgot—
I've forgot the shoes.
Oh, that's not a spider.
That's Cthulhu.
The dark lord.
I'm gonna be sacrificed!
Wow.
(canned growling)
Nice try!
Aahh, yes!
(yelp) My god!
More for the Awakening!
Fantastic! (guttural laughter)
Am I gonna be sacrificed?
This is the one!
Oh, they seem to like me.
No, no, I'm good!
Kevin!
No!
(evil cackling)
(cackling)
No!
Wow, he got him so good!
Yes!
Oh!    Yay!
(applause)
(menacing) Happy Halloween!
Aah! Tom's coming!
Happy Halloween!
He just sent that man
into the stratosphere,
and that's the first time
he has ever scared a person
in a haunted house
in his entire life.
As soon as I entered
that room with Cthulhu,
I'm like, something bad
is gonna happen here.
This is like, they put this
big old thing together.
Are you okay?
I was at a ten.
Alright?
(laughs)
Mike, good job.
Thank you so much.
He was the other one
in there, wasn't he?
We all set that up so you'd think
the one scare in the room was over.
And then I was
the bonus one there.
I didn't see him either.
I was too busy looking at all the
fake mannequins you had around.
Yeah.
The guy with the knife
sacrificing the person on the table.
Thanks for coming out, Kevin.
Thanks for...
Thanks for letting me out.
And thanks for letting me
come out and see everything.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]
That was awesome.